um can you confirm that you have the
game ball from tonight I I have no idea
I'm not going to lie I have no
idea I don't know you know I really
don't know I don't know I have the ball
but I don't know if it's a game ball it
doesn't feel like the game ball to me
it's it feels like a brand new bow um
like I can I can tell you know from um I
played what 35 minutes today you know I
know how the the game ball felt you know
the the ball that I have which I'll take
and I'll give it to my mom for sure but
uh I don't if it's actually the game BS
but it's it's it's okay you know um life
continue I don't actually I don't even
have the game B from um which hurts me I
don't have the game B from game six in
the NBA Finals I don't have a game B
from that either um but uh I just it's
just so fortunate I've never seen I've
never seen this before I feel like you
can't I don't I don't know I don't even
not even going to comment on that I
don't know if I have the game but to be
honest with you and that's what you you
thought they had the game ball that's
why you ran after them in the T I knew
they had the game ball I don't I didn't
think I have they had the game ball I
knew they had the ball first of all you
cannot I don't know how it works but um
I assume like I cannot
just walk in in any I didn't let I play
and just take the ball like Dame was
fifth of all time you know um I scored
60 at the end of the day
like I the ball that they gave us I
offered it to Dame like I scored 60 he
scored multiple times 60 he scored 70
and you know he should have the ball but
um at the end I don't think it's fair
for you know anybody um and I understand
like look look I understand when you
score your first uh point in the in the
NBA like you want to have the ball or
whatever the case might be um but the
end of the day like we talking about the
the guy that um just um jumped over
jumped over you know skipped uh K corver
in the all time uh list and uh in my
opinion I feel
like we should all you know kind of stop
what we're doing and appreciate
greatness because uh as C cover said in
the video how many people can say
they're top five in something that they
do he's he made it you know the most
threes in maybe history I'm you know I'm
right there I'm chasing him you know I'm
2003 away but um yeah I don't know it's
at the end of the day good team they
played extremely hard they have a great
coach that uh they very well coach and
uh you know that we are going to see
them in Janu January again and we know
that they're going to you know play at
the at the best and uh we got to be
ready you know and um if we're not ready
they going going to beat us like the
last two times that we saw them yianis
uh Rick Carlile said that in the tunnel
one of your guys players elbowed the
Pacers GM in the ribs did you see that
are you aware of that no no I I didn't
see
it I didn't see it um so I I don't I'm
not going to comment on something that I
didn't see and I don't I don't want to
create a narrative that maybe that
happened and he actually did not happen
uh maybe coach um coach saw that and um
I'm going to respect his uh View and if
you want to ask me more question you
know next game you guys can ask um about
the whole situation and who you know
elbowed who I didn't see
that